Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before
my hands start shaking familiar else
you posted a question.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
This episode is brought to you by Linkedin
and their job recruitment platform,
which offers a smarter system for the
hiring process if you've ever hired anyone
or attempted to do it,
you know that finding the right people
can be extremely difficult and if you
don't have a direct referral
from someone you trust,
you're left to use job boards that don't
really offer any real world networking
approach. And when I mean by
that is in contrast, Linkedin,
which is the world's largest
professional network,
has a built in ecosystem that allows
you to not only search for employees but
also interact with them and their
connections and their former employers or
colleagues in a way that closely
mimics real life communication.
More than 70% of the workforce in the u
s uses Linkedin and more than 22 million
professionals view and apply
to linkedin every single week.
Unlike generic job boards,
linkedin considers skills,
experience and location to
match you with candidates,
making it easier to find
quality candidates. And uh,
maybe above all you can directly
contact, uh, candidates,
connections to get a good sense of if
they are a good fit for your business.
So visit linkedin.com forward slash Tim
and receive a $50 credit towards your
first job post.
That's linkedin.com forward
slash Tim Tim for $50.
This episode is brought to you by
Ray Daleo, his new book principles.
If you're a frequent
listener of this podcast,
you might recall that ray
was a guest on the show.
Has episode was extremely popular and in
that episode he shared his thoughts and
everything from how he makes investment
decisions to cryptocurrency and beyond
his story. Ray Daleo, you should
look him up for sure is fascinating.
He started his investment company.
Some people would call it a hedge fund.
There are different names.
Bridgewater associates out of a
two bedroom apartment at each 26.
Now it has roughly $160 billion in
assets under management over 42 years.
He's built Bridgewater into what fortune
considers the fifth most important
private company in the u s along the way,
Daleo took tons and tons of notes
on what worked, what didn't work,
and it was refined over time for
training purposes with his employees,
managers and so on.
Daleo became one of the
100 most influential people
in the world according to
time and one of the 100 wealthiest
people in the world. According to Forbes.
In this book,
principles which has a permanent spot
on my bookshelf also has blurbs and
testimonials from people like Bill Gates,
Michael Bloomberg, and many, many more.
Ray shares in those pages,
the unconventional principles that he's
developed or find and use over the past
40 years to create unique
results in both life business,
certainly in investing and which any
person or organization can adopt to help
further their goals.
These principles are what he believes
is the reason behind his many,
many successes and principles.
The book also offers a clear,
very straight forward approach to decision
making that Dhalia believes anyone
can apply both in life and work.
I highly, highly recommend it.
It will help you to become
in almost any context,
a clearer thinker.
So visit principles.com for more details.
Amazing that he actually has that URL.
It's visit principles.com for more
details and to pick up a copy.
Check it out.
Hello Ladies and gentlemen,
this is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show.
More specifically another edition of the
Tim Ferriss radio hour where I go back
through the 300 plus guests
who've been on this show.
Think about the conversations and look
for patterns or themes that we can
explore and this episode
we'll dig into travel.
One of my favorite topics and I will take
partial credit or blame in advance as
it might make you want to quit your
job and head off to the airport with a
backpack.
Coincidentally exactly what I am doing
tomorrow and why I'm recording this intro
way,
way past midnight now.
I've interviewed some fascinating
people from around the world.
It's kind of crazy to think that this is
my job. How happy am I? How lucky am I?
And in the next hour,
we will actually travel around
the world with them in a way,
because we recorded these
episodes all over the planet.
We'll also explore specific tips and
strategies from our conversations related
to how they think about travel,
how they personally travel,
the tools and gadgets they use, and the
role that travel might play in your life.
First I talked to the one and only
Rolf Potts, the author of vagabonding,
one of my favorite books of all time.
Some of you may know starting around
2004 I traveled the world for roughly 18
months after this complete implosion
and deciding to either shut my business
down or completely reinvented
and extricate myself.
The lessons learned over those 18 months
form the basis for much of my first
book,
the four hour workweek on that journey,
which ranged from the back alleys
of Berlin to lakes and Patagonia.
I had next to nothing, one suitcase,
one backpack, and only two books.
One of those books was Walden by Henry
David Thoreau naturally and the other was
vagabonding subtitle and uncommon guide
to the art of longterm world travel
written by Rolf Potts,
which is about a lot more than
just travel people, you know,
they put off what they really
want to until they're too old
to actually write,
do it next.
My friend Kevin Rose and I share our
travel experiences while sitting on Tatami
mats in a traditional, in the Japanese
hillside in Kanazawa specifically,
and we cover everything from how to cope
when not speaking the local language to
how Kevin has to hide his tattoos,
those tattoos in certain countries,
including Japan,
went in to use the spa and she goes,
tattoos and I said yes,
and she handed me flesh colored tape.
Then I talk travel and diving adventures
among other things with Phil Cogan from
the amazing race and I just wrote down
everything that I felt like I had all the
time in the world to do, to get out, to
go, okay, this is not a dress rehearsal.
You can die, you will die. You don't
know how long you've got before you die.
And of course the incredible.
Kevin Kelly and I get into our
favorite travel tools and gadgets.
What else do you have in your backpack,
which is stuffed here in the
back of our car right now?
So let's jump right in.
Rolf Potts at Rolf Potts on Twitter has
reported for more than 60 countries for
the likes of National Geographic Traveler,
the New Yorker,
slate.com outside the New York
Times magazine, the believer,
it goes on and on and on.
Sports illustrated, national
public radio, you name it,
his adventures have taken him across
six continents and include piloting a
fishing boat 900 miles down the Laotian
or Laotian metcon hitchhiking across
eastern Europe, traversing Israel
on foot, bicycling across Burma,
driving a land rover across South America.
Sounds like a long, long ass trip.
And traveling around the world for six
weeks with no luggage or bags of any kind
off is perhaps best known for promoting
the ethic of independent travel and his
book on the subject of vagabonding,
which I mentioned before,
subtitle an uncommon guide
to the art of longterm.
We'll travel has been through 28 printings
and translated into many languages.
It is also,
by the way,
the reason I started the Tim Ferriss Book
Club and produce an audio book of this
book because it could not be found in.
That bothered me when you can find out
all about that@audible.com forward slash
Tim's books if you want to see the other
books in that selection. But backdrop,
he won the 2009 Lowell Thomas Award from
the Society of American travel writers
and became the first American author to
when Italy's prestigious coveted Chatwin
prize for travel writing.
Many people fantasize about travel,
yet they never follow through.
They never the book their trip
and take those first steps.
Ralf explains in what follows the concept
of vagabonding and how it differs from
just another vacation.
I like that you bring up the idea of
fantasizing about travel because I think
it's something that everybody does
and it's one of those top three,
if not top two or one things that people
dream about that and you and you see it
in the movies all the time. Um, and in
fact, I this in vagabonding, you know,
the heist movie where the whole goal
is to have this complicated, um,
robbery so they can have enough money to,
to move overseas to a wonderful place.
And as I say in the book, is that you
don't need to rob a bank to do that.
In fact, you can do that
for a cost that is equal to,
and sometimes less than your cost of
living in a major American city. Uh,
and so I think an important principle
I bring up in vagabonding is saying,
don't, don't put this off if you're
dreaming about travel. And most people do.
And you know, and if you don't
worry about travel, that's fine.
But I really address these travel dreams,
which are so common that don't wait until
you get to tell you're too old because,
um, you know, retirement isn't
necessarily the best time to, to, uh,
to do something like this. And
in fact, a Henry David Thoreau,
I think Walden Woods, the other book
you'd, you took on your travels, uh,
talks about how people, and I'm not
quoting him directly, they, you know,
they put off what they really want to do
until they're too old to actually do it.
And you know, that's a paraphrase.
Um, and so if you are 18, 28,
you know, 38, 48, whenever
you're them about travel, put,
make your goals soon and,
and don't put off those goals because
they're very attainable. And you know,
I think there's a lot of fears that
are tied in to confronting vagabonding,
which you asked me if the,
for the definition,
it's not combining as longterm travel.
It's not just a vacation,
it's not a week or two off. Um, that, you
know, society gives you as a vacation.
It's six months or two
years or s you know,
six weeks that you make for
yourself to travel in earnest,
not as a consumer experience, not
as a vacation, but as a, you know,
a more deeply meaningful life experience.
And as a way to actualize
your wealth of time.
And I think this is an idea we'll come
back to a lot and it's something that you
write about as well as me
as the idea of time wealth,
the idea that your experiences
are more valuable in life.
Then the things that you accumulate and
the things that are always being touted
as the most important things in life.
So travel is a great way to cash
in on your time wealth. Um, and,
and vagabonding just by definition
is a more meaningful way of travel.
It's a way of slowing down and really
discovering parts of yourself instead of
just buying a lot of experiences,
which is,
which we've sort of been conditioned
to do, uh, as American consumers.
My first vagabonding trip was
20 years ago this year. Um,
oddly enough and having an
anniversary. Thank you. Thank you.
It was just this time that I was,
that I was straggling back to Kansas
after having this amazing eight month trip
around North America and it was a
trip that I thought would be my last,
I thought I would get travel out of my
system so I could become a responsible
American workaholic. And then maybe
return to travel when I was old. But you,
you mentioned the idea of fear and
the fears I had going out were,
um, you know, is this going to
be expensive? It's going to,
is this going to be dangerous,
am going to come back and be
compromised professionally.
And all of those sort of turned into the,
into the opposite that it was
a lot safer than I expected.
It was a lot cheaper than I expected.
And I came back and for 20 years I've
been integrating, uh, travel, uh, with,
with a professional life that continues
to diversify. I continue to, to,
to do other things to make money while
at the same time having big swaths of
time to travel. And I'm not suggesting
that everybody needs to, you know,
become a vagabond or for a 20 year chunk.
And in some ways I travel a lot
less than I used to, um, you know,
10 or 15 years ago.
But it's something that you can do.
It's an option that you can
have and it's not an APP,
an option that you wait for life
to give you, you create it. Uh,
and so I'm a big believer in the active,
uh,
aspect of vagabonding
of saving your money.
But the lottery is another
metaphor I use a lot in,
in bag of bonding that people keep waiting
for the lottery to reward them. Um,
but as,
as we all know,
the odds that you're going to
win the lottery is pretty low.
But we've already won the lottery.
We're born with time wealth and so it's
just a matter of creating these travel
experiences or these time
rich experiences, uh,
through things like simplicity and a,
just the decision to make
these sort of things happen.
What type of sites or resources would
you recommend to people who are trying to
find a comparable folks?
Let's just say people who will help them
alleviate their fear of travel or just
in general, what type of online
resources do you recommend?
Um, well Google for one. I mean
if you just Google, you know,
35 year old years old, two
kids, one year of travel,
then odds are you'll find 20 blogs of
people in that demographic who are doing
just that. Um, so,
so really be the unabashed and very
specific about googling you know,
your fears or your demographic
and just see who like you is,
is out traveling the world. There's
a lot of great traveler communities.
I've been affiliated with
boots and all.com, um,
since the very beginning of vagabonding
and part of their emo is just sort of
creating community and, and
uh, and, and support, uh,
for people.
And they have,
they have blogs and resources on their
site and there's other travel communities
as well. It's boots, the
letter n all.com, right? Yeah.
B O t s n a l l.com.
And they'd been operating out of Portland,
Oregon for years.
And I'm just quietly been doing very well.
The nice work of reassurance
and saying, oh, so you, so
you're worried about it. Uh,
and around the world
flight, well, here's what,
around how around the world
flights. Look, you know, you're,
you're worried about a certain
situation, you know, here's,
here are some resources for
that. And, and they're not alone.
I'm most familiar with them because we,
we've been,
we've sort of shared a similar
mission for a long time,
but there are big communities of
travelers who, who are happy to help,
uh, and, and sort of help new
newbies feel better about these, uh,
prospects have of longterm travel
for you in,
and perhaps there are older examples,
but you mentioned that
you're, uh, you're too,
you're taking a trip before
we started recording, uh,
and you're doing a home swap. Is that, is,
would you mind perhaps elaborating on,
um,
how some of those options work,
those that you're familiar with,
because I think that many people who
consider travel think in terms of one of
their main expenses being, staying
in a hotel. Right. Uh, and,
uh, I'd love for you to share
any of your thoughts on that.
Yeah. Well, it, it's shifted the
way the travel world works in, in,
in some ways that are delightfully
convenient. Uh, and, and,
and in some ways that are
a little bit strange. I,
I think that technology is one of those
double edged swords that in some ways
has turned us into insufferable
micromanagers on the road.
Can you elaborate on that?
Yeah. Well, I'll, I'll start with
the negative. Um, you know, I,
I the tribal culture which I started in,
which was 20 years ago,
but really my more international traveler
travels or more like 15 years ago. Um,
it's about showing up in town and
knowing that when you get there, um,
the unexpected awaits you that you,
that you're going to walk
to the hotel district,
you may have a guidebook with
some hotel recommendations. Um,
but you're going to shop for your hotel.
You're not gonna find a deal online.
You're going to walk in there,
you're going to see the room. Um,
you're going to haggle because in,
in, in all throughout Asia, you know,
basically any place outside of the
industrial world, prices are up for grabs.
And haggling in person is so much more,
it gives you so much more
leverage than haggling online.
Cause you can go and look at the room
and physically leave, uh, if the,
if the owner doesn't give you a
price that you're, that you're into.
And so these days it has become so
convenient. Not always a bad thing,
but it has become so convenient that
people just assume that the best deals to
be had are the ones online.
And then pretty soon you've locked in
your traveling for six weeks and you know
where you're sleeping
every night and advanced.
And it really compromises the flexibility
of travel and the serendipity of being
inspired by a place and thinking, I'm
going to stay here for a few days. Or Wow,
I just met this traveler who told me
about this great place up in the mountains
and I'm,
I'm not going to go to Varanasi,
I'm going to go up into the
Himalayas and spend my time there.
This technologically enhanced micro
managing cuts into that serendipity in a
certain way. And it also
connects us to home and, and
again, it's a two edge thing.
Um,
social media and the,
and the constant connectivity that
comes with smartphones, for example,
allows us to really find things
that we couldn't find before.
But it cuts into the idea of wandering
around and finding things by surprise,
finding things organically and letting,
letting it get destination reveal itself
to us on his own terms instead of sort
of finding that place as a
consumer before we get there. Um,
and a lot of technologies have eliminated
things like loneliness and boredom, um,
which sounds good and is good to a certain
extent, but loneliness and boredom, um,
can lead you to those moments that,
that sort of force you into
a new version of yourself.
They force you to be more extroverted
day. Totally, totally agreed.
They force you to read the local
newspaper instead of, you know,
looking through your Facebook
feed. Right. Uh, uh, and so that's,
that is what we're up against
with this technological,
these technological advances.
And I don't want to be in the grumpy,
older traveler because I remember
being being 20 and listening to these,
you know, baby boom era hippie sort of
lecture me on how travel used to be,
you know,
back at a time when telephone answering
machines and credit cards were seen as
this decadent form of technology. Um, and,
and so I know that there are younger
travelers who don't know anything but the
constant conductivity of travel.
Um,
but unplugging is important and we can
talk more about that if, if you want.
Um, and we can also talk about the pluses
and there I have many recent examples
about how technology has have helped
this recent home home exchange.
It's just a longtime friend who lives
in Brooklyn. She's a writer, uh,
and she wants a quiet place.
I have 30 acres in Kansas and so I get
an awesome pat in Brooklyn for a week and
she gets a quiet farm in
Kansas for a time. Uh,
I think in places and more expensive
places like Europe, you know,
the hostel was your go to.
It was where if you wanted to save money,
you would go to the, to
the youth hostel. Um,
and it was a great place to meet people.
You get a cheap bed, you went, you,
you would forego a few amenities, but
you would hang out in the hostel. Well,
I went to Amsterdam, uh,
this summer, uh, I teach,
I teach a writing course
in Paris every summer.
And my sister and my nephew came and
visited me and we wanted to go see
Amsterdam.
And using Airbnb,
I was able to get a full cottage,
a 15 minute train ride outside of central
Amsterdam for about half the price as
a hostel for three people
in the center of Amsterdam.
So instead of staying at, at
at somewhat grungy, hostile,
and the red light district,
um,
we were staying in this little
town filled with windmills, uh,
and we had our own house to ourselves and
we could just walk down the street and
get groceries. And so Arab,
that was an airbnb hookup.
Couchsurfing is a similar,
has similar benefits. Uh, it,
it just allows you to break out of not
only that old hotel set of assumptions,
but also out of the
hostel set of assumptions.
The idea that the cheapest option in
any place is going to be a hostile,
especially traveling in groups for the
three of us. If I had been alone, maybe I,
maybe the cottage wouldn't have been as
cheap as the hospital with three of us
where you're getting hostile
one bed at a time. Um,
we just got the perfect place
to stay through airbnb. Uh,
and so those services
and even social media,
even going on Facebook or Twitter and,
and I'm not a big believer
of tweeting while you travel.
I think that that really puts you into
this home mindset and it pulls you out of
the place where you are.
And the point of travel is experiencing
what's before your eyes and not what's
coming across your social media feed.
But before your travel,
before one's travels,
I'm a big fan of throwing,
throwing out a tweet or Facebook
post that says, Hey, look, I'm,
I'm going to be in this place.
What are some suggestions? Uh,
and that is something that
didn't exist 10 years ago, uh,
and is not tied to a business or social
networking thing like Airbnb and couch
surfing,
but it could just be that your buddy
from high school has a friend who was in
the military in Germany and they have
an ex girlfriend who lives in Stockholm
and suddenly you have a place to stay,
uh, through very random circumstances.
And so that kind of,
it's,
it's the old model of sitting
in the hostel or sitting
in a guest house or a bar
and an exotic part of the world talking
to the sixth travelers who are there
with you and them giving you advice
on points further down the road.
That principle has been taken to
social media and through networking.
That's another way that
technology has allowed that,
that that old hostel room
is actually killed the,
at the literal hostel room where people
are now staring at their phones in the
hostel room.
But is it as expanded the virtual hostel
room where instead of talking to the
six travel or is your width physically,
you can be talking to 600 travelers
through your networks who might have some
good advice for you.
Okay.
This next segment was
recorded in rural Japan.
Late one evening with my friend
Kevin Rose at Kevin Rose on Twitter,
affectionately known as Kev Kev by those
in the know serial entrepreneur rolled
class investor in all
around wild and crazy guy.
We've been through a lot together and
here we discussed Japan how to do it
cheaply in many other things and the
tips in this next segment apply to just
about anywhere,
not just the land of the rising sun
and we are at [inaudible] is the name of
the place and if you hear any waterfall
like sounds in the background,
that is because we have a natural onset
bringing water into the rooms where
there are wooden tubs that are
effectively indoor, outdoor.
There's an open wall,
so you look out into a forest slash
hillside and the steam pours out into the
great outdoors. It is winter. So
there's tons of fog and mist and so on.
It's just a magical place. Yeah,
it's, it's absolutely beautiful.
And one of the reasons why I
chose this place to stay is one,
I had never stayed in a Ryokan like
traditional Japanese house before and I
always wanted to do
that. Um, and number two,
when you're talking about it ons
and like a natural spring, um,
it's very difficult because in Japan
if you have any tattoos whatsoever,
you are forbidden from
doing the [inaudible].
Like you can't go and baths public baths
because they say that you're a yakuza.
Yeah. It's associated with
organized crime. So if you
have tattoos as Kevin does,
yes, my little pony on
both delta, it's beautiful.
I can see a long haired but the tassels
and it'd be quite a breathtaking thing.
It is breathtaking.
And uh,
you are not allowed to go to public
baths or most of them also true in say
hotels where they have beach front,
you're not allowed to go on the beach if
you have exposed ends who's also hotels
when you're going to just use their kind
of spa. Cause I went in there one time,
um, I was staying at a, I think
it was a peninsula and um,
went in to use the spa and she
goes tattoos. And I said yes.
And she handed me flesh colored tape.
I got like a little square of tape and,
and I have a few,
I was like, I'm going to need the
whole role. And it ended up not being,
I didn't actually happen, I didn't go
in so I would have been kicked out.
But this is nice.
It's in our room.
So every single room here has
its own little private bath,
hot water being piped in and it's,
it's been very relaxing.
And that should say also, we're not
going to talk about Japan the whole time.
But I do think Japan is worth
highlighting for a few reasons.
I mean I was an exchange
student here at age 15,
which was really my first time abroad.
And that year completely changed my life.
I lived with host families,
I went to a Japanese school,
I was the only American in my class photo,
which is very easy.
Where's Waldo all in school uniforms.
So like crew cut,
Whitehead,
and then all Japanese gets about 5,000.
And it has proven to be such a subtle
and nuanced culture simultaneously.
You can come here, someone who doesn't
speak Japanese get completely lost,
be completely bewildered. The English
level is generally pretty low here.
So it can be a totally alien environment
where you can't read any signs and it's
not dangerous.
And the people will go above and beyond
to try and kind of decipher what you're
saying with your hands.
Well, not only that,
so why don't you tell the story of
Tony and the earphones? Well, it,
what are your phones? Your phone city
dropped on the salt. Oh yeah, yeah.
So two days ago, well, there was two
stories. Okay. So this is classic, uh,
Tokyo for you.
Um,
and it's part of the reason why I love
Japan so much is like the people here are
just so friendly and I'm really
concerned with your wellbeing.
So Tony,
one of the,
the members that was traveling with us
that is traveling with us, he dropped his,
uh, his headphones and just, you know,
we're talking standard kind
of apple headphones, you
know, white cord, whatever.
And we walked into a coffee shop.
And now just for context,
this is on one of the busiest streets
in a shopping district in Tokyo. Yeah.
So there's people just, you know,
I knew in New York City, yeah,
just like all over the
place. Just, you know,
probably stepping on the
headphones and whatnot.
Somebody on the second floor of a building
across the street was looking out the
window, saw that these, these, these small
white headphones fell out of his pocket,
ran down the stairs,
grab the headphones,
it figured out which coffee bar we had
gone into and then proceeded to enter in
and hand back the headphones,
which was just nuts.
And then on top of that,
the exact same coffee bar
I had gotten out of a taxi,
left my cell phone in the taxi.
And you know,
of course when you're in the
states you'd like, Shit. Like my,
my cell phone's gone. I'm never
gonna see it again. And um,
so I use find my phone, you know, the,
the apple built in features so you
can see where the your phone is.
I used it off of my wife's
cell phone and you know,
it's 2025 minutes away from where we're
at in a taxi. And I'm like, God damn it.
Like, how am I ever going to get this
back? And I pressed the button too,
which sends a signal to the cell phone.
So it sends out an audible alert to the,
you know, so anyone who ever
is is nearby can hear that.
All of a sudden I'm watching on GPS,
the phone starts getting
closer and closer and closer.
This driver drives all the way back.
20 plus minutes comes up the stairs to
the coffee shop where you drop were I
left him and then hands me my phone
back. I try to tip him, you know,
I'm thinking like in the states, you
know, you give somebody 20, 40, 50 bucks,
I thank you so much. He wouldn't
accept my tip and was just so polite.
Bowed to me and left. It's
just like, oh man. It just,
it makes you, when you live with, when
you live in the states, you're just like,
what,
what happened with a few friends with us?
And it also makes you feel
like a, uh, in many, many,
many instances and uncivilized Harry
Savage. That's what I'm saying.
Like you wake up,
you know,
you're going to be ashamed of at least
17 things that you do that day. Uh,
but it's,
it's a wonderful environment.
And one thing that I want to
underscore before we move on,
and I'm sure we'll come back to it,
is that you don't have to have a lot of
money or spend a lot of money to enjoy
Tokyo.
This is a common misconception.
It can be extremely expensive, but it
doesn't have to be extremely expensive.
And certainly Japan as a whole doesn't
need to be extremely expensive.
When I was here at 15, I had no money
whatsoever. And you can, for instance,
find stores that you would recognize like
seven 11 that are completely different
from the equivalent at home. And you
can go into a seven 11. For instance,
and you can grab one of my favorite
on the go bites, which is Onigiri.
These are rice balls wrapped and dry
seaweed and filled with various meats,
vegetables or fish,
say tuna whenever it might be,
and those cost about 110 yen.
So let's just call that a dollar.
And you can find those at
seven 11 store called Sun Cus,
s u n k u s or Lawson.
It's packaged in such a way
that you pull apart the plastic,
which keeps the seaweed separate.
It automatically wraps this rice triangle
and you have effectively an entire
meal right there for somewhere between one
and $2. Yeah, well you know it's funny,
I don't know if I told you this,
but I was here with David Chang.
I'm sure a lot of people
are familiar with him,
but he's one of the probably the
top five chefs in the United States.
Very famous Momofuku Mofo. Yeah,
just like Bar, right? Yeah.
Milk bar and a,
we happen to be here on the same trip
with some friends and he was ranting and
raving about these seven
11 a egg salad sandwich.
And it's like, you know, a multi,
like, you know, it was, yeah,
I think it has three Michelin Stars
at one of his restaurant. I mean,
I'm top of the world chef freaking out
about a seven 11 different seven 11 the
United States. Yeah. I mean,
not high end food by any means.
I mean a couple of bucks
for this egg salad sandwich,
but prepared with like my
beer says prepared with pride.
Yeah. There's so much. A couple of
other go tos that suggest in Tokyo,
if you can get a ticket, go
to the Jubilee Museum. G, H I,
B l I museum, which is the museum. It's,
think of it as the Disney Museum
for the Walt Disney of Japan.
And that's a Miyazaki Heiau. He did
spirited away. My favorite movie,
my neighbor Totoro a whole long list of
blockbuster and kind of a genre defining
anime film send it is, it is
one of the most incredible, uh,
museums I've ever been to. It's in the
middle of what they call me. Taka forest,
which is right next to her is, you know,
cause she had a Koan and then, uh, a lot,
a lot of things in Japan are also free.
You can go to [inaudible],
h a r a j u k you,
where you can find on the weekends
Elvis impersonators doing their dancing.
This has been going on for decades now.
And you can also go to
[inaudible] dot doughty,
which is I guess tuck a stuff street
or alleyway where you find dozens or
hundreds of teenagers in
high schoolers doing cosplay.
So they wear these crazy outfits and walk
up and down the streets or showing off
the weirdest outfits imaginable or into
that. A lot of people are into it. Like,
do you, are you kind of like
when you see a cosplay or you,
cause it's like a sexual thing?
Well, for, so I, you know,
I think that for some people
that might be part of it,
but I think that it's just a form of,
of hyper expression in a culture where
a lot of people feel very repressed or
overly polite. Most of the time. Yeah.
And so then they blow it
out on the weekends and they
like put in pink contacts
and white hair and 12 inch platform shoes
and wear the wackiest shit imaginable.
Yeah. Maybe Walter, uh, in the, in
the states cause plays like a bigger,
cause they'd dress up like
video game characters and
things like that when, sure.
You know, hey comicon
and whatnot. Oh yeah.
Well there are a lot of things that are,
that's not really Japanese cosplay though.
There are a lot of things that are regular
and other countries that end up being
adopted by weird niche groups in the u
s and take on in some cases like creepy
or weird or elements, right?
Like tango in Argentina,
normal tango in some places in
the United States. Super Weird.
And I'm just saying that as someone who
loves tango and dances dances in many
places, but primarily in
Argentina, way back in the day.
Same thing with Japanese stuff.
It's like, oh Monga cool.
And then you find like a little subculture
in a given city in the u s and you're
like,
wait a second,
it's all 40 year old guys who are like
reading creepy half Porno Hentai Manga.
Okay. I don't think I'm going to
hang out here. Right, right. Anymore.
So a segue. Yes. How do we
stay away from that? Uh,
let's Segue,
fall from hint,
the hint that you're going to look
up those people interested there.
There are two books that have helped me
review and prep for this trip in terms
of Japanese that I'd like to suggest
people check out if you're interested in
Japanese, uh, very short. And I was able
to get through these really quickly.
The first is probably for people who
speak more intermediate Japanese,
so you'd want some basics first,
but it is 13 secrets for speaking
fluent Japanese. And this is by,
I think it's Giles' or
Giles, g. I, l. E. S,
let's say Giles Marie and u R. R a. Y.
So 13 secrets for speaking fluent
Japanese. Very, very helpful.
And then the second is maybe
a bit dry for some people,
but I like very concise grammar summaries
that are quick reference and this is
Japanese verbs and essentials of grammar
and that is by Rita lamp can l a m P K
I n
fill Cogan
k e o g.
H a n at Phil Cogan on Twitter has worked
in television for almost 30 years on
more than a thousand program episodes
in more than a hundred countries.
His work has earned him numerous
awards including 10 that's right,
10 primetime Emmys.
He has pressed best known
as the co-executive producer
and host of CBS is series
the amazing race,
but there's much more to fill
story including unbelievable
bucket lists near to
the experiences and all sorts of
other adventures. And misadventures.
I was doing a story about a 22,000 ton
shipwreck that had sunk in in New Zealand
and it was down about 120 feet underwater
and it was on its starboard side.
22,000 tons is like,
it's as big as you know,
a cruise liner that you see going
around at the ports around the world.
And big, really big and 120 feet, uh,
is for people who've never
done any scuba diving in.
Unless you have special equipment.
I mean that's not a lot of bottom time.
Exactly. So most recreational divers
get certified to dive to about 60 feet.
The best stuff that you see underwater is
generally in the first 30 feet because
once you get past 30 feet, the color,
it changes you, you lose all the reds
and everything becomes very blue. Um,
so I always say to people,
look, you don't need to go deep.
And unless you're going
onto a wreck or something,
there's some real reason to go deep. The
only reason to go deeper, as you know,
if it is a wreck,
you can get great diving in 10,
15 feet of water with the
Carl close to the surface.
The colors are brighter and so on.
But this wreck was deepened. And, and,
and as you said,
the deeper you are,
the faster you chew through air and you
eat up air and that affects how long you
can stay down. And the longer you're
down deep, the more nitrogen you get.
In your blood. And so it's, it,
there's a real science to diving and
you have to be super careful as you're a
diver. I am. Yeah. So you, you understand
seeing people get nitrogen narcosis yeah.
Ad At exactly 120 feet.
I saw a guy start to tr,
he tried to take off all of his gear
and just drop it in a small group and he
was stopped. But that was the guy
that worked at Chippendales. I no, no,
no. A different guy. Okay.
No, but I, but people, yeah,
I've seen the same thing to take the
regulator out and they start having
conversations with fish and it's not a
good idea. No. It getting narked. Um,
yeah. So that's all the more reason
to get properly certified. So, um,
I was with some very experienced divers
and way more experienced than me.
And they were,
they were doing the salvage him.
We were going to be the first
people to shoot on the ship,
get to go inside the ship and explore it.
And the cameraman that I was with,
the also very experienced,
but because there was a bit,
because the,
there's so much silt inside the boat
and there was a current as well rolling
through the book. We were, we, and we,
in those days we were shooting on film.
It's not like today where you
could go down with a great group,
a Gopro and some lights and you know,
you could film for a couple of hours.
We had a two and a half minute roll of
film in a 100 foot daylight spool role
that was in a little
housing inside the kit.
So literally that's the only amount
of footage we had to shoot on film.
That's how long I go back.
So that the plan was that we
would go into the ballroom of the,
of the ship and big,
big ballroom and then the crew would come
in from another door and we would meet
in the middle so that we didn't stir
up all the silt going into the same
entrances and we'd swim towards each
other. They'd get us coming towards them.
And so we go down and what I know
now is if you go into a wreck,
you tie line on the outside of the rec
so that you have something to follow out
if something goes wrong.
These guys were so familiar with the wreck
and so experienced and knew the place
so well they didn't tie align on and I
just sort of followed them in not knowing
that that was sort of what you should do.
And you know,
the other rule with diving is
you never leave your dive buddy.
So I'm following this guy and I was too
scared to tell him because I was trying
to be a man that before
I'm really claustrophobic.
So I go in this little doorway and it
would've been like imagine a small window
like two by three.
We go through this little port hole and
then we start weaving our way through
the ship. And I, as we go on deeper and
deeper and deeper into the shipwreck,
I'm completely disoriented
and I have no idea where I am.
My hand sweats just listening
to the description. Oh yeah.
And I started to breathe like breathe.
But every time I sort of like was at the
point of tapping him to go, you know,
I gotta get Outta here.
I feel panicky.
He just kept disappearing deeper and
deeper and deeper in another corner,
another corner. And I thought, and
he was moving quickly cause he's,
he's used to being in this wreck.
They're doing the salvage on this thing.
So finally we come into an opening and
then he shines a light around and there's
this huge ballroom. Now the ship is on
its starboard side on its right side.
So all the tables on a ship,
shipper, old, bolted to the floor.
So imagine the tables
on a right angle to us.
And then he gestures to
me to hold onto the table.
And then he told me on
the surface that he,
we were going to switch out the lights,
uh,
to save battery power cause it's called.
And now we don't have a lot of, uh,
and we've got seven Mil wetsuits on is
pretty cold and you can feel kind of the
current pushing through the ship. And
that's why we were holding onto the table.
So we didn't drift. And you know, through
the room and now we're looking ahead,
any sort of points at me and looks ahead
and says that's where the crew is going
to come out. And I knew that that's
where they're going to come out.
So I was like,
okay,
so we're waiting with the lights off in
the dark and I'm processing all of this
and starting to try to slow my breathing
down and like stay calm. It's okay.
You know, you're with an expert,
everything's good. And uh,
after what seemed like, like minutes
all I want it to turn my light on,
but I also didn't want to do it cause
I thought he'll think I'm a wimp.
Like why am I turning off?
I just want to turn my light on to see
where I was like to have sent some sense
of where I was.
He flicks his light on.
Like in Halloween,
when you take your life,
put it on the Chin and you make
yourself look scary. Right.
That's all I remembered.
The light went on.
It's pointing from his chin looking up.
He looks scary.
Then he gestures me with his hand,
puts it out in front of me, like wait.
Then he points at my hands on the table
like and gestures for me to hold onto
the table and then boom,
he just disappears around a corner
and I don't have my light on.
He's got his light on it and the
light disappears and he's gone.
Well in that moment I'm
like, why is he leaving?
Why did he just leave?
So in my haste to find my light too,
I've start flailing around,
let go of the table and I feel myself
drifting away from where the table is and
moving,
drifting into the ballroom and I just
went into a mad panic and I couldn't find
my light. By the time I found my light,
I had silted up all the water around me.
I couldn't see anything.
And now I don't know where the table
was that I was meant to hold on to.
And I'm looking ahead. I can't
see any lights, I can't see him.
And I started to breathe really,
really fast. And now you're a diver,
you understand this.
But when you dive in for anybody who's
never had a regulator in their mouth,
if you breathe too quickly,
there's a little diaphragm that allows
for exhalation and inhalation in the,
in the regulator that you put in your
mouth to suck in air. If you go too fast,
the diaphragm can't keep up with the speed
of inhalation and exhalation and then
you start to suck water.
And then so I started like taking little
bits of water in and I'm beating the,
the, the, the valve and
just panicking like mad,
mad panic and I thought I have to get
out of here and all your weight or you
want to do is just get out. Right.
But I don't know how to get out.
I don't know where up and down is.
I don't,
the bubbles don't go up when the ships
on his side like that and your deep down
they hit the walls and then they
run up the walls. They follow.
We had pass and I thought,
I have no idea where I am right now.
I can't even see where the table
is. And panicking, panicking.
And I knew that someone had died in their,
uh,
someone had gone in there
and got disconnected from
a group and he had died and
drifted off into the ship and died.
I also knew that one of the engineers
never made it out when the ship sank in
the first place. So, and just to set
the stage also for people listening,
I remember when I did a dive
at the blue hole in Belize,
which is about 120 feet.
This is when this guy got narked.
It takes so long to get down
because you're equalizing. Yup.
By the time you get down,
I at least we were told at the time with
the gear we had, you have eight minutes.
Yeah. So all of this is happening.
Yeah, very quickly. Very quickly,
very quickly. And we, we weren't on
nitrox. Nitrox as you know, is a, is a,
is a mixed gas that you can get where it
has more oxygen and less nitrogen so it
increases your bottom time.
So this is pre nitrox days and so yes,
you're absolutely right.
We had a very limited window,
which is why he must have gone off to
find the crew because he realized we were
eating up a lot of time. And where
were they? Where were the crew?
Well I don't remember exactly
how I got from there to the boat,
but this guy obviously
came back to get me.
And really it's all a
blur between panicking,
mad panic eyes like wide like
sources to being on the boat,
to looking up into the sky and seeing
the most amazing blue I'd ever seen in my
life. Like just look like
totally surreal. And then,
and I'm lying on the ground like breathing
and I look up and all these faces
looking down and it, Phil,
you're good, you're good. I'm
like, yeah, yeah, I'm good.
I'm good. Like trying to play like
nothing happened but my heart is pounding,
pounding and I was so like the feeling,
the feeling of euphoria,
the,
the relief of being alive to
know that I was alive was,
was like nothing I'd ever experienced.
And it really was oldest stuff.
It was as if my Iq went up 25 points
in that moment. You know what I mean?
Because I was like, how dumb we you that
thought you were going to live forever?
How dumb were you that you did?
You've been doing all these dumb
things in your life and you have real,
really have no purpose in life.
And I started to think about this is
all happening while I'm having these
conversations with them. But
I'm like, I'm thinking, man, I,
I love girls and I haven't even like
really explored that whole world. And
that's like the second or
third thing that comes up.
It was actually right out there. And
of course in my sexual prime, I mean,
come on right up there. I don't
want to say it was the first thing,
cause I don't want you to
get the wrong idea about me,
but it was up there and I
was like, damn, you know,
you've got a lot to do with your life.
So no,
but there were all these things that
came to me and a lot of them were very
selfish. I was 19 years old. So, uh,
I got myself together and I,
I wanted to find a piece of paper
and a pen and I just wrote down just
everything that I felt like I had all the
time in the world to do and that I had
to get down on a piece of
paper to get out to go, okay,
this is not a dress rehearsal.
You can die, you will die.
You don't know how long
you've got before you die.
You better figure out what you're doing
with your life and you better get on
with it straight away.
And one of the first things on my list
was go back in the shipwreck seriously
because I thought I cannot
walk away from this fear.
I was so petrified of what
had had happened and I,
and I decided I would explain
to the diver, you know,
that I found it challenging.
He knew that shuttling Djing,
but I said it was like kind
of like falling off a horse.
I really felt like got to get back on,
got to get back on.
I have to go back because if I let this
fear get on his time with some string or
so, well I didn't actually go back
with him cause I didn't even, I didn't,
I didn't have time to do the lesson
about this spring. Yeah. But I,
but I went back with,
by disclosing a little more by fear to
the other diver and it was more honest.
And, and then he, when he knew that
and we had to get this thing shot,
he was obviously more aware of,
you know, he thought I was so,
cause I was so gung Ho,
like he didn't have any indication
that there was any fear in me at all.
But then I kind of said, you know, listen
to man, I really freaked out. He goes,
oh no kidding. And I, and I
said, but I need to go back.
We've got to go back and do this. And we
went back and we did it and we shot it.
And that was the start.
That was the first thing I'd ticked
off my list question for you.
So when you decided to go back down,
you know,
as you're descending petrified and getting
ready to go through that tiny opening.
Yeah. What was the self talk, I
mean it's a long time ago, but what,
what is your self talk like
in a moment like that? Well,
it's something that I've
used a lot since then,
which was instead of
internalizing everything I
looked out and what I realized
was that this guy was super experienced
and had been down on that shipwreck many
times and come out of there
successfully many times.
And if I followed his procedure and
if I observed him being an expert,
doing something and looked out at that
rather than turning it back into my own
head about what I didn't know and what
I couldn't do, that I was in good hands.
So ever since that moment and all
the crazy things that I've done,
I've taken a tremendous amount of comfort
in being surrounded by people who I
know are better at me at doing something,
who have tremendous expertise
at whatever they're doing.
And to really observe them in that
moment when they are in there,
when they are using expertise
than they are constantly.
They have taken that has taken possibly
at least 10,000 hours to get to and and
to look at it in a way like, wow, how
cool is that? I'm with this person,
man or woman,
whoever it is that is allowing me and
given me the privilege to be with them to
do what they do so well and
there are specialist in there.
Good and so you would be explicitly
reminding yourself of all these things if
you're going into a situation
that is provoking nerves and fear,
is that the voice inside the head?
It is. It's, I made up
a quote which I really,
that I share with a lot of people which
is focus on what you do have and what
you can do instead of what
you don't have and what you do
up next.
Kevin Kelly at Kevin two Kelly the
number two at Kevin two Kelly on Twitter
might just be the real life,
most interesting man in the world.
He'll be my vote.
I think maybe tied with another Jen
who's going to come up in a second.
Kevin is senior maverick
at wired magazine,
which he co founded in 1993 he also
cofounded the all Species Foundation,
a nonprofit aimed at
cataloging in identifying every
living species on earth in
his spare time.
He writes bestselling books,
many of them like the inevitable subtitle,
understanding the 12 technological
forces that will shape our future.
And by the way,
he's considered an incredibly accurate
futurist is predictions of pan out over
and over again, even though he spends
part of the year with the Amish.
But that's another story.
He cofounded the Rosetta project,
which is building an archive
of all documented human
language and serves on the
board of the long now foundation.
He alongside Stewart brand and others,
Stewart brand might be the person tied
with Kevin for the most interesting man
in the world nomination.
He alongside Stewart brand and others
is also investigating how to revive and
restore endangered or extinct
species. The woolly mammoth. Yup.
Jurassic Park stuff. But in real life
I'd always wanted to travel with Kevin,
uh, for, for 10 plus years.
I would say I wanted even before I knew
him to travel with Kevin and I finally
got my chance and it is
represented in this segment.
We traveled through Uzbekistan together.
Long story,
Kevin touches on a lot of cool stuff and
we had a blast recording it in the back
of a car as it spread
through the mountains.
So I hope you enjoy it as much as I did.
Hi,
this is Kevin Kelly.
I'm sitting in the back of a car crossing
in a mountain pass about 2000 meters
in the attention mountains in Uzbekistan.
In a Spec of Stan is a central Asian
country that's generally south of Russia,
north of Afghanistan, and next to
all the other stands like Kazakhstan,
Turkmenistan,
Tajikistan sitting next to me as we
crossed the mountains is Tim Ferriss,
the legendary explored her and
explainer of worldclass performances.
And we're going to do a
joint, uh, recording. Uh,
Tim's going to tell us about his favorite
for cool tools and we'll find out what
he's up to lately.
Tim,
why don't you tell us
about your first cool tool.
Okay. The first cool tool, if
we're sitting in the back here,
we have the bags around us,
bottles of water,
a bunch of different gadgets
and objects piled in my lab.
The first that I can talk about is
actually in my other piece of luggage.
I don't have any checked luggage and it
is a check it that I roll up and travel
with constantly.
It's from a brand called now and a you,
I believe it's based in Portland and you
can think of it as a blazer or a riding
jacket.
And what what makes it unique is
a number of different factors.
A, and you can roll it up and throw it
on to say a black tee shirt and you look
like you're ready for a business dinner
or a formal or semi formal occasion.
So it saves me the trouble of packing
a lot of collared shirts for instance.
And there are collared
shirts that don't wrinkle,
but they do take up more space than
say, black tee shirt. So this now,
and it could be, uh, I have, uh,
several different models at home,
weather resistant. Of course it was
designed in the Pacific northwest,
you would expect that which
comes in handy. So that
would be my first cool tool.
Uh, plenty of pockets of, but there our
lapels, so you can get away with murder,
you could wear it in a light rain or you
could wear it at a nice dinner and it,
it is an incredibly
flexible piece of clothing.
So one of the hazards for me anyway,
if I tried to roll up a jacket,
I never quite get the wrinkles out.
So no iron shirts,
you can kind of hang in your hot
shower and it will dissipate.
How does work in terms of
an wrinkling it or do you,
does it just magically unwrinkled so
this particular jacket has a number of
features,
I think that disguise wrinkles and that
there's also that just the material
science aspect, the, the fabric blends
that are used tend not to wrinkle,
number one.
Number two,
it has folds and pockets and the
lapels that for whatever reason,
make any wrinkles less noticeable.
And then there's the color.
So if you want to avoid problems
with wrinkles, generally,
at least in my experience,
you want darker clothing so that
under light you're not casting,
you're not having shadows cast
across or beneath the wrinkles.
So this is a charcoal color jacket.
It's kind of like your typical suit,
check it length,
or is it more like a
outdoor jacket at the waist?
I would say typical dinner jacket
length. Uh, so it's not getting cutoff.
Doesn't show off any midriff for
those of you were looking for that.
You're out of luck. Yeah. Uh,
so you'd be able to see your belt if it
were on buttons in the front. Right. Okay.
So that's,
and it's very lightweight and about tell
the readers about how big it compresses
into if you were to roll it up.
Well,
and if you want to know how
to roll up a jacket like that,
well you could actually
go online and look at how,
say a judo uniform is folded. And, uh,
if you roll it up,
well you are looking at,
let's just say the,
the bottom three quarters,
meaning it'll cover the very bottom,
a fabric of a standard sized school
backpacks are not thinking about a hikers
backpack. Uh, so if, if I had to
estimate, I would say we're looking at,
I get it down to about a role that is
10 inches in length and about a three to
four inches in diameter.
Well that's very impressive.
I carry a lightweight down Jack if they
compress this into something very small,
but it's certainly not as fancy or,
or you know,
suitable for dinner jacket like yours is.
And I mean a couple of other
tips for folks and the by,
I'm by no means say hyper minimalists
and say Appalachian trail hiker or
anything like that.
But I also have for instance,
a synthetic because I
don't want to lose the uh,
insulating ability if it,
if it gets wet. I have a,
a synthetic down vest that is
also stuffed into this backpack,
which I can put on top of that sort of a
fancy looking jacket in the case that I
need more warmth. Yeah, that's
brilliant. That's a really good hack. So
again,
that's called the now
check it and a, you know, no.
Okay. And approximately what's it,
what's it cost? Just give me a
range. That's really good question.
I bought it a long time ago. It's not
a, it's not cheap, but then again,
if you're comparing it to any type
of dinner jacket or outdoor jacket,
it's not horribly expensive.
I'd say it's in the one 50 to three 50
range if I had to guess. Okay, good.
That's fantastic.
So what else do you have in your backpack,
which is stuffed here in the back of our
car? Right now my, in my bag of tricks,
I have a uh,
a logic tech Bluetooth keyboard. And, uh,
just to put this in perspective,
it is about the slightly larger
than say a paperback book,
like a five by eight inch trim paperback
book is narrow enough that I will very
often stick it into a journal
to protect it. Uh, meaning it's,
it's probably the width of
eight to 10 paperback pages, uh,
and it holds a charge very,
very well.
So I use this oftentimes if I
have any issue with my laptop,
I can pair it to my iPhone,
which is a larger sized iPhone and balance
the iPhone or lean it against saying
a,
a glass of ice tea.
And I can get any type of writing
done that I need to get done. Also,
if I feel like taking a day trip
but not taking this backpack,
which is one of my main pieces of
luggage and stuffed full of stuff,
it's kind of heavy.
I can take the,
I can take the keyboard and my iPhone
and head off to some coffee shops saying
10, 15 minutes away without
carrying all of my gear with me.
So I'm going to try to describe this
a little bit further. It's very,
very thin and very lightweight.
It feels like it's made out of aluminum
and it has kind of a matte texture,
matte finish on it. It
feels very velvety. Um,
and it's uh,
mostly charcoal color with white letters.
And so this would serve as
a keyboard with a phone.
Uh, and, and the keyboard itself is pretty
large in terms of your finger spacing,
so there'd be no cramping.
That is really cool.
Yeah,
it's a great device.
I've had this now for I would say two
years and I have never had a technical
fail.
So as a form of backup,
I find it to be very cheap insurance
because as you can see in person,
this is lightweight enough that I'm not
going to get scoliosis for having this
as additional piece of gear.
I just stick it,
stick it into a large format journal or
even a magazine and I can travel with
it. Yeah, that's really cool. And
so it pairs up through Bluetooth,
I imagine, right? That's right.
Right. So you compare it up to a, an iPad
if you want it to as well as a phone.
If you happen to be carried. I definitely,
yeah. So, um, what's that again?
This is a larger tech Bluetooth keyboard.
Okay.
And we'll put the exact model
in the show notes for everybody.
And uh, next up we have uh, these,
these all kind of traveled together.
I've very rarely take these out
of my backpack. In this case.
This is Max earplugs,
silicone your plugs,
which unlike foam earplugs or not inserted
into the ear canal and then left to
expand,
these are effectively smeared over the
ear opening and you have in all caps,
do not insert Justin uncover ear opening.
These I found through swimmers in fact,
uh,
and they are very waxy,
and almost look like candies,
some type of Caramel,
but they're white colored and I find
them to block sound much more effectively
than any type of foam your plug,
although there are some good ones on the
market to be sure to use them just once
or can they be reused or recycled or the
last a little bit then you have to get
grungy or what, what, what's the
use? I definitely reuse these.
I would say if I had to guesstimate,
I would say four to five
nights and then they'd,
they start to lose their
adherence because they get, uh,
they get less tacky over time.
The most important feature or benefit
that I don't want to overlook is that as
someone who tends to
rotate from back to side,
so I sleep on my back and on my side
foam earplugs won't very often hurt.
They'll get pushed into your ear
when you roll onto your side.
That is not the case with these.
Uh, so, uh, it's over side sleepers.
This,
these aren't real,
a real cool tool because it allows you
to sleep on your side while you have
these earplugs in. Definitely. And even
as someone who kind of tosses and turns,
in my case,
I don't tend to wake up on my site,
but I'm constantly going onto my side
and foam ear plugs off and will wake me
out. Okay, cool.
And is this mostly just used for
sleeping or could you use these,
do use these for other sorts of sound,
but maybe these,
these earplugs, uh, live in each of
my bags that I tend to travel with.
So I have, I have redundant caches
of earplugs, one in this bag,
one in my other bag. And sometimes
I'll even have them at jackets,
mostly for sleeping,
definitely heard who's sitting
on an airplane and you're
trying to read and just
want to drown out the sound.
Then you can use it as well for sure.
Or you're swimming and you want to avoid
swimmers. Okay. Right. Cool. Okay. So, um,
what's your fourth? A cool tool.
My fourth cool tool, and I might,
I might,
I might go over slightly here,
but by my fourth cool
tool is a neck pillow.
And I want one of those. I've tried
many different neck pillows. Yeah.
Most of them are very uninspiring and
even less effective for helping me sleep.
Uh, this, and I'll do my best here. Cabo
cut by, I believe his, the presentation,
C A, B, e,
a u and it has evolution pillow written
on the side. You can see that it,
it's compresses down very
nicely size of a cantaloupe,
like a small, like a small
cantaloupe or a large grapefruit.
Now you can certainly compress it more,
uh,
in the actual bag that it comes in,
allows you to wrap it up and then
compress it down to a smaller size.
And it was just very nice in essence,
memory foam,
neck pillow that also clips in the front.
And what I've found is not only does it
help me sleep if I'm sitting upright,
but it's also very,
very helpful for getting to
sleep when I'm laying prone,
whether it's on an airplane or even
in a hotel room if the pillows are of
dubious quality.
And do you have to inflate this,
uh, with like pumping Erin blowing
air into it or is it self expanding,
its self expanding? Uh, so it, you
could think of it almost like a sponge,
like material that you can compress
down and then when you release it,
it's uh, inflates or I should
say rather expands automatically.
It is one of those horseshoe
shaped items or is it a,
just a little kind of weds assists behind
your neck? It is a horseshoe shaped,
uh, if you imagine a horseshoe being
hung or around the back of your neck, uh,
that is the shape can clip in the front.
And the design is such that there's a
ridge that supports basically the ACIP
it'll area the fact that the
base of the skull, so it's very,
very ergonomic. It's, it is.
It's the most comfortable
neck pillow that I have found.
And so I am pretty light. It's a little
bit bulky, but it's pretty light.
Yeah, it's, it's lights. And
as far as neck pillows go,
not very bulky at all,
but if you're going to have a neck pillow,
generally speaking,
in my experience at least it's going to
be inflatable and quite uncomfortable.
Or you're going to end up with this
type of compromise. And this is,
this is the best I
found, right. So it does,
it'd be you could pretty easily
disappeared Joe daypack. Oh,
I think it absolutely could.
And certainly if you wanted you could
lash this to the outside of a pack.
I happen to have enough space
in my bag so I include it,
but you can lash it or hang
it on the outside. Okay. One,
one other cool tool that you have,
which is more common here than I would
have expected, but in retrospect,
I shouldn't be surprised. It is
very, very hot here. It can get very,
very hot and the sun is extremely powerful
to the extent that we visited a solar
furnace not long ago,
that can be used to melt various objects,
absurdly high temperatures.
Thousand degrees centigrade.
Yeah, exactly. Uh, and uh,
you have,
well our guide has our esteemed guide as
an umbrella smart move to create shade
wherever he wants it.
And you have an umbrella,
but you made a modification
to your umbrella. Yeah.
So I just had an ordinary,
cheap Chinese black really
compact umbrella that I
carry in my little camera bag
all the time and I spray painted the
top of it silver so that it reflects the
light and it makes it a little bit cooler
on the inside because just with the
black umbrella,
it tends to absorb that infrared and
reradiate it back down on your head.
Um,
having a silver reflective layer announces
at least 60% of that packet to the
sky and it's a lot cooler. And, um,
there are versions of the silver umbrella.
They're extremely lightweight.
They're not as collapsible as the ones
that have what they're made for hiking
there, there, there, I think,
just call it the silver dome,
if I'm not mistaken and are
way only a few ounces. Um,
and people out west, if you're
claiming even at the high altitudes,
um,
a lot of the long distance hikers now
carry and an umbrella portable shade and
they walk along hundreds of
shades shade files in. Um,
and it really makes a huge difference
when you're backpacking because you can
really work up a sweat and the hat
doesn't allow your head to cool off.
But the umbrella does
well. There you have it folks, the Tim
Ferriss radio hour with just a handful,
the guests and experts I've spoken with
across more than 300 podcast episodes
and I myself and Jonesing to throw on
the backpack some sandals and hit the
road, which is exactly what
I'm doing tomorrow. So the
timing could not be better.
And the Tim Ferriss radio hour
continues to be an experiment.
So please let me know what you liked,
what you didn't like,
how it can be improved, how my voice
grates you, haunts your dreams,
what topics or themes you'd most
like me to explore. In other words,
I'd love any and all feedback so you know,
on a Twitter ad and that's usually the
best place to get my attention at t
Ferris,
t f e R R I s s and let me
know and until next time,
as always,
thank you so much for listening.
Hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've or that I've been pondering
over the week. That could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's
four hour workweek.com all spelled out
and just drop in your email and
you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by
re Dalia, his new book principles.
If you're a frequent
listener of this podcast,
you might recall that ray
was a guest on this show.
Has episode was extremely popular and in
that episode he shared his thoughts on
everything from how he makes investment
decisions to cryptocurrency and beyond
his story. Ray Daleo, you should
look him up for sure, is fascinating.
He started his investment company.
Some people would call it a hedge fund.
There are different names.
Bridgewater associates out of a two
bedroom apartment at each 26 now it has
roughly $160 billion in
assets under management.
Over 42 years he's built Bridgewater into
what fortune considers the fifth most
important private company
in the u s along the way,
Daleo took tons and tons of notes
on what worked, what didn't work,
and it was refined over time for
training purposes with his employees,
managers and so on.
Daleo became one of the
100 most influential people
in the world according to
time and one of the 100
wealthiest people in the world.
According to Forbes in this book,
principles which has a permanent spot
on my bookshelf also has blurbs and
testimonials from people like Bill Gates,
Michael Bloomberg, and many, many more.
Ray shares in those pages,
the unconventional principles that he's
developed or find and use over the past
40 years to create unique
results in both life business,
certainly in investing and which any
person or organization can adopt to help
further their goals.
These principles are what he believes
is the reason behind his many,
many successes and uh,
principles.
The book also offers a clear,
pretty straight forward
approach to decision making
that Dhalia believes anyone
can apply both in life and work.
I highly, highly recommend it.
It will help you to become
in almost any context,
a clearer thinker.
So visit principles.com for more details.
Amazing that he actually has that URL.
It's visit principles.com for more
details and to pick up a copy,
check it out.
This episode is brought to you by Linkedin
and their job recruitment platform,
which offers a smarter system
for the hiring process.
If you've ever hired anyone
or attempted to do it,
you know that finding the right
people can be extremely difficult.
And if you don't have a direct referral
from someone you trust your left to use
job boards that don't really offer
any real world networking approach.
And when I mean by that is in contrast,
Linkedin,
which is the world's largest
professional network,
has a built in ecosystem that allows
you to not only search for employees but
also interact with them and their
connections and their former employers or
colleagues in a way that closely
mimics real life communication.
More than 70% of the workforce in the u
s uses Linkedin and more than 22 million
professionals view and apply
to linkedin every single week.
Unlike generic job boards,
linkedin considers skills,
experience and location to
match you with candidates,
making it easier to find
quality candidates. And uh,
maybe above all you can directly
contact, uh, candidates,
connections to get a good sense of if
they are a good fit. For Your Business.
So visit linkedin.com forward slash Tim
and receive a $50 credit towards your
first job post.
That's linkedin.com forward
slash Tim Tim for $50 off.